COMMITTEE TO ORDER.
WE'RE GONNA BE STARTING WITH S.
B. EIGHT FIVE SEVEN IN HOME
SUPPORT SERVICES.
DISCUSSED.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN STERN VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS ANY COST WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THIS BILL WHICH APPLIES ONLY TO
LOS ANGELES ORANGE MERCED
COUNTIES REQUIRES THE COUNTY OR
PUBLIC AUTHORITY IN A RECOGNIZED
EMPLOYEE ORGANIZATION.
UPON REQUEST OF EITHER PARTY TO
MEET AND CONFER REGARDING THE
STRUCTURE TIME AND MANNER OF THE
ACCESS OF THE EXCLUSIVE
REPRESENTATIVE TO AYE H. AS FAST.
PROVIDER ORIENTATIONS.
THIS MAY INCLUDE FOR PROVISION
OF THE BILL IS AYE BECOMES AN
OPERATIVE ON JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THE BILL ALSO
APPROPRIATES TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL.
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
I'M BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MISTER.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO.
I UNDERSTAND THE BILL ALLOWS THE
REPRESENTATION ORGANIZATION --
ACCESS TO THE ORIENTATION --
IS THAT THE ONLY ORGANIZATION I
WOULD BE ABLE TO PRESENT IN
OTHER WORDS IF THERE WAS AN
ORGANIZATION THAT WATER TO MAKE
A PRESENTATION ON THE
ORIENTATION --
THAT.
CONVINCED EMPLOYEES THAT
BELONGING TO THE REPRESENTATIVE
ORGAN ORGANIZATION WAS NOT THEIR
BEST INTEREST WITH HAPPY ALLOWED.
IT'S SILENT ON THAT AND
PARTICULAR QUESTION BUT I WOULD
RECALL THAT THERE WAS ANOTHER
TRAILER BILL HEARD BY THIS
COMMITTEE SEVERAL WEEKS AGO THAT
HAS MOVEMENT MANY MORE BROAD
PROVISIONS REQUIRE BURKE
REGARDING THIS PARTICULAR
PROCESS --
BILL BEFORE YOU THE SILENT ON
THAT.
I RECALL THE TRAILER BILL ALSO.
PROVISIONS OF THAT TRAILER BILL
WAS THAT NO ORGANIZATIONS LOUD
ADVOCATE --
THROUGH IN A GOVERNMENTAL
SETTING AGAINST BELONGING.
TO THE THE UNION SO I JUST THINK
IT'S FAIR THAT IF.
THE UNION SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
THE ORIENTATION THAT OTHER
ORGANIZATION SHOULD AS WELL --
IT SO THAT THAT'S ARE ONE OF THE
REASONS OF A BIG PROBLEM WITH
THIS TRAILER BILL BUT THANK YOU
FOR ANSWERING THE QUESTION
[inaudible]
OTHER COMMENTS.
BUT TO TRY.
THE READING OF THE ANALYSIS S.
B. R. --
EIGHT FIVE SEVEN IS --
CLEARLY ATTEMPTING A TO ORGANIZE
AYE H. ASSESS EMPLOYEES ARE
ULTIMATELY.
TO BE UNIONIZED.
WAS SO ADVANTAGE OF OUR
UNIONIZING --
SUCH.
OUR I ITCH ASSESS OUR EMPLOYEES
ARE IF THEY DO.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY ARE THE
PEOPLE PROVIDING.
AREA VULNERABLE A POPULATION AND
THAT IF THE ARE ARE ORGANIZED TO
AND EVENTUALLY COME.
TO A THE POINT THAT --
LABOR NEGOTIATIONS.
STONE AGREED YEAH.
ALTON BECAUSE OF THE MATTERS ARE
AND THAT THEY CHOOSE TO STRIKE
THAT THEN --
THE CONSEQUENCES ARE OF THAT THE
NO STRIKE.
WHEN NO WILCO WERE CHAU WHAT BUT?
TO TAKE CARE OF THE ARE.
ARE ELDERLY.
AND A WHO ARE IN OUR VERY.
SYRIA IS --
CONDITION IN THE VEIN NEED.
EVERY MINUTE DOT HOW WELL DONE
WHAT WOULD BE THE BENEFITS THAT
FOR THE UP PUBLIC.
BECAUSE OF THIS BILL IS SO
CLEARLY.
YEAH JAKE POOR WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
SO.
I I JUST AS PROVIDERS ALREADY I
AM ARE --
GENERALLY REPRESENTED BY --
UNIONS IN THAT IN THE STATE --
SIMILAR --
TO OTHER --
YEAH YOU KNOW --
UNION REPRESENTED EMPLOYEES
STATE THEY ARE PAY A FAIR SHARE --
TO BE REPRESENTED SOAKED
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING DOES
HAPPEN NOW CURRENTLY BETWEEN --
COUNTIES OR PUBLIC AUTHORITIES --
AND THE UNIONS.
SO THIS ISN'T THE END AND THERE
IS ALREADY A PROVISION IN.
AND LAW THAT --
I BUT YOU KNOW ALLOWS UNIONS TO
MAKE A PRESENTATION DURING THESE
ORIENTATION.
I CAN SEE THE DIFFERENCE JOB
RIGHT THE OF BEING REPRESENTED.
BY UNION GROUP WAS OF THE OTHER
GROUP OUT ON BEHALF OF DISA.
OUT WORKERS OF OUR AYE IT'S A
SATISFIED THAT'S ONE THING.
BUT ORGANIZING THEMSELVES.
AND NOT EXERCISING DEAL RIGHTS
THAT'S SO TWO DIFFERENT MATTER.
OKAY ANY OTHER COMMENTS
[inaudible]
QUESTIONS.
WE HAVE OUR PUBLIC COMMENT IN
FAVOR OF S. B..
EIGHT FIVE SEVEN ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT OPPOSE.
COMING IN FAVOR.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MY
NAME IS CHRISTINE ABBAS HAMILTON
I'M HERE REPRESENTING YOU W..
PATHS ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE
THIRTY WE REPRESENT OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND OF OF THE IHS
AS PROVIDERS.
AND TO ANSWER THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS QUESTION OF ALL
OF OUR CONTRACTS.
INCLUDE NO STRIKE PROVISIONS
BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF THE
WORK THAT OUR MEMBERS DO --
WE WOULD NEVER ASK THEM TO GO
OUT ON STRIKE INTO NOT --
PROVIDE SERVICES TO THE
VULNERABLE OF FOLKS THAT THE
WORK FORCE SO THE THIS IS
DEFINITELY A DIFFERENT TYPE.
OF OUR COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
STRUCTURE I JUSTICE IS PRETTY
COMPLICATED --
WE HAVE AN EMPLOYER ALREADY --
WE THE STAY AT TIMES IS
CONSIDERED A JOINT EMPLOYER
DEPENDS ON WHAT THE ISSUE IS THE
THE LAWS ACTUALLY PRETTY
COMPLICATED ON THAT BUT I CAN
SPEAK TO THE STRIKE PROVISION
VERY CLEARLY --
WE'RE WE UP --
SUPPORT THE BILL --
VERY MUCH BECAUSE WE REPRESENT
WORKERS IN ORANGE AND IN MERCED
COUNTY AND WE VERY MUCH ARE
SEEKING THE CLARITY THAT THE
BILL PROVIDES WHICH IS THAT WE
HAVE THE RIGHT. TO MEET AND
CONFER WITH THE EMPLOYER OVER
THE STRUCTURE TIENEN MANNER OF
PROVIDER ORIENTATIONS THOSE
ISSUES OUR CAUSING TREMENDOUS
CONFLICT FOR US.
IN THE COUNTIES WE BELIEVE THE
BILL WILL GIVE US THE CLARITY
THAT WE NEED AT A AS TO WHAT OUR
RIGHTS ARE. TO BE CLEAR THIS
RIGHT ALREADY EXISTS FOR EVERY
OTHER PUBLIC WORKER IN
CALIFORNIA THIS IS A QUESTION OF
PARITY FOR US --
YOU WILL HEAR FROM THE FOLKS WHO
GET UP IN OPPOSITION THAT THEY
OPPOSE THE BILL BECAUSE IT'S NOT
WORKABLE IN ITS CURRENT FORM.
THEY'RE GOING TO USE A LOT OF
SEMANTICS.
THAT THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A COUNTY IN A PUBLIC
AUTHORITY --
FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT HAVE
SERVED ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS I'M NOT SURE HOW
MANY THERE ARE ON THIS COMMITTEE.
ANYONE WHO KNOWS.
I JUST US AND LIFE IN THE
COUNTIES KNOWS THAT COUNTIES
ABSOLUTELY CONTROL PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES.
THERE IS NO CONTRACT THAT THE
UNION CAN NEGOTIATE THAT IS NOT
SIGNED OFF ON LITERALLY BY A
VOTE OF THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
SO ANY NOTION THAT THE PUBLIC
AUTHORITY IS GOING TO NEGOTIATE
SOMETHING THAT THE CONTRACT OF
THE COUNTY DISAGREES WITH.
IS GIBBERISH AND THE SMOKE
SCREEN TO CREATE OPPOSITION OVER
SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T EXIST
WHAT THEY REALLY ARE OPPOSE TO
FROM THE COUNTY PERSPECTIVE IS
LOSS OF CONTROL.
OVER UNILATERALLY IMPLEMENTING
HOW THEY WANT THINGS TO GO IN
PROVIDER ORIENTATION SO TO BE
CLEAR THAT'S REALLY WHAT THE
PROBLEM IS.
IT'S NOT A QUESTION OF A WHO IS
TECHNICALLY THE EMPLOYER THE
COUNTY IS THE ONE WHO.
A CONTROLS ORIENTATIONS AND A
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES DON'T AGAIN
THAT'S NOT TRUE IN EVERY COUNTY
AND OF PUBLIC AUTHORITIES
FUNCTION --
AS A ENTITY SIMPLY TO SERVICE
THE EMPLOYER OF RECORD WE ALL
KNOW THAT THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ABSOLUTELY CONTROLS.
EVERYTHING RELATING TO THE TERMS
AND CONDITIONS OF IHS US WORKERS
SO TO BE CLEAR THAT'S WHAT
YOU'LL HEAR --
VERY HAPPY TO TALK THROUGH THE
TECHNICAL ASPECTS OF THAT WITH
CLARIFYING QUESTIONS SO.
ON STE BEHALF OF OUR WORKERS AND
OUR MEMBERS WE VERY MUCH ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL THANK YOU.
THE CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BRIAN NELSON THEM HALF
OF THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES --
FOR THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY
STATED WHEN A STRONG SUPPORTER
OF SADDAM FOR PIECE OF
LEGISLATION I BELIEVE THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT CLARIFYING.
ODD I CHANGED TO THE EXISTING
SET --
MISSPENT HAMILTON STATED --
I BELIEVE THAT IS ABSOLUTELY
PRUDENT AT THIS TIME --
TO INSURE THAT THERE'S GREATER
CLARITY AS WELL AS BALANCE IN
TERMS OF HOW WE SETTLE THESE
ISSUES AT THE TABLE SO.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT REQUEST
OVERS RIVERS WOULD WORK
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST NOT BUILT
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE WE OWE
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
ON ASSOCIATE MY COMICS THOSE OF
MY COLLEAGUES FROM A UW AND
ASKED ME A WE AGREE THAT.
INCREASING ACCESS AND
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN --
I'D JUST AS PROVIDERS AND THEIR
EXCLUSIVE EMPLOYEE
REPRESENTATIVE WILL ENSURE THAT
THOSE WORKERS WHO ARE USUALLY
AND ISOLATED SITUATIONS WHERE
THEY WORK ALONE.
I DON'T SHOULD THOSE WORKERS
HAVE -- FULL%
ACCESS TO THE INFORMATION THE
RESOURCES AND THE TOOLS NEEDED
TO BETTER SERVE THEIR CLIENTS IN
MATTERS OF THE PUBLIC SO FOR
THOSE REASONS RESTAURANTS
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU SEEING NO OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION.
I AYE JUSTIN GARRETT CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES US
SINCE MY TESTIMONY WAS ALREADY
PREVIEWED I'LL TRY TO KEEP IT
SHORT -- AS
AS WAS INDICATED THERE IS A
COMPLEX EMPLOYMENT STRUCTURE FOR
RIGHTS THAT'S THERE ARE SPECIFIC --
DUTIES THAT COUNTIES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHICH INCLUDE
IMPLEMENTING PROVIDE
ORIENTATIONS.
THERE ARE SPECIFIC DUTIES THAT
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHICH INCLUDE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING --
ANIMOSITY CAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES.
SO ESSENTIALLY THAT THE CHANGES
THAT WHAT THIS BILL DOES
DIFFERENTLY IS IT WOULD MANDATE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING BY PUBLIC
AUTHORITIES OVER SOMETHING THAT
THE COUNTIES ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
IMPLEMENTING WHICH IS THE
PROVIDE ORIENTATIONS.
IT WOULD ALSO INTRODUCE THE
POSSIBILITY OF BINDING
ARBITRATION TO OCCUR I'M WHERE
CONDITIONS COULD BE OPPOSED ON
COUNTIES THAT THEY WEREN'T A
PARTY TO THE BARGAINING OF THAT
THEY WOULD POTENTIALLY OBJECTS
HILL AND THAT IS ANOTHER
DISTINCTION AND HOW THIS BILL IS
DIFFERENT I'M WE WERE NOT
CONSULTED ON THIS.
LANGUAGE OR THESE CONCERNS ABOUT
PROVIDE ORIENTATIONS PRIOR TO
THE BILL GOING INTO PRINT AND SO
WE HAVE WORK --
TO WORK WITH THAT THE SPONSORS
AND AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT
ALTERNATIVE APPROACH WE PROVIDED
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS TO PROVIDE
AN ALTERNATIVE APPROACH.
I AM IN ORDER FOR THE PROVIDER
UNIONS AND THE COUNTIES TO REACH
AGREEMENT ON I'M PROVIDING UNION
PARTICIPATION UMAP RIGHT OR NO.
THOSE MOMENTS WHEN THEN I MIGHT
ALSO NOTE THAT THE THREE I
COUNTIES THAT.
ARE DOES NEED IN THIS BILL THEY
ALL COMPLY WITH STATE LAW
RELATED TO PROVIDE A UNION
ACCESS THAT PROVIDE ORIENTATIONS
AND I'M AWARE OF SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES OF THEM.
I'M WORKING WITH PROVIDING
UNIONS AND AGREEING TO THINGS
THAT ARE BEYOND STATE LAW IN
TERMS OF THE THE PROVIDE YOU
NAME GETTING TO SPEAK FIRST.
OR I'M OTHER GROUPS NOT BEING
ABLE TO PUT A SPIN OFFS RIGHT
ORIENTATION SO FOR ALL OF THOSE
REASONS --
WE REMAIN OPPOSED THIS BILL
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEARCH OUR MEMBERS TO MEN OF
OURS UPON THE URBAN KINDS OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN OPPOSITION
ONE ALLY MY COMMENTS WITH SIX
ACTED Q..
THANK YOU NEED ADDITIONAL.
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
OKAY -- WE
WILL BE MOVING ON TO A. B.
EIGHTEEN THIRTY EIGHT JUST OR
JUST TO MAKE A NOTE I A. B.
EIGHTEEN THIRTY EIGHT AND S. B.
EIGHT SEVEN TWO WERE IDENTICAL
WE WERE.
WE ARE GONNA BE SHOWING BOTH OF
THEM ARE THERE WAS A TECHNICAL
AMENDMENT [inaudible] TO AB S.
B. EIGHT SEVEN TWO TO HAVE A
REGARDING A TECHNICAL ISSUE
REGARDING CANNABIS.
SO WE ARE GOING TO HEAR BOTH
BILLS ONE THE ORIGINAL BILL AND
THEN ONE WHICH IS THE BILL WITH
THE TECHNICAL AMENDMENT SO YOU
CAN -- FEEL
FREE TO DISCUSS BOTH OF THEM
TOGETHER AS AT AB EIGHTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT NEXT BE EIGHT SEVEN
TWO MISS COST.
THANK YOU FOR AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT THIS BILL WOULD PROHIBIT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM IMPOSING
OR INCREASING ANY TAXES OR FEES
ON GROCERIES WHICH DO NOT A
INCLUDE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES CAO.
PRODUCTS WERE CIGARETTES UNLESS
BOTH OF THE FOLLOWING CONDITIONS
ARE MET.
THE TAXES GENERALLY APPLICABLE
TO A BROAD RANGE OF BUSINESSES
BUSINESS ACTIVITY OUR PRODUCTS
AND THE TAX DOES NOT IMPOSE A
HIGHER TAX RATE ON ANY
PARTICULAR CLASSIFICATION OF
GROCERIES THE BILL ALSO INCLUDES
A DEFINITION OF GROCERIES.
THE BILL GRANDFATHERS IN TAXES
ON GROCERIES THAT WERE PASSED
BEFORE JULY FIRST TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND SUNSETS AND IS
REPEALED ON JANUARY FIRST --
TWENTY THIRTY ONE WE'D KNOW THAT
ALTHOUGH THIS IS AN
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSAL AND
NORMALLY WE WOULD NOT SUPPORT A
MEASURE THAT LIMITS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS REVENUE GENERATING
AUTHORITY.
ON WE ARE AND CONCERNED ABOUT
SOME OF THE PROVISIONS IMPACTS
ON OF THE INITIATIVE ON THAT ARE
ALIGNED WITH THIS PARTICULAR
BILL ON STATE SPECIAL FUNDS.
AND I IN LIGHT OF THAT AS
PASSAGE OF THIS BILL A RESULTS
IN THAT PARTICULAR INITIATIVE
BEING PULLED THE ADMINISTRATION
WILL SUPPORT.
I'M I WOULD KNOW THAT ON IN THE
LA OWES INITIATIVE --
FISCAL ANALYSIS THE NOTES THAT
THE INNOCENT INITIATIVES PASSAGE
WOULD BE AND WOULD HAVE
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND ALTHOUGH.
IN THEIR ANALYSIS THEY SAY THE
IMPACT TO THE STATE IS MINOR.
I THINK ON BASED ON THE ALICE
PREVIOUS TESTIMONY IN THE SENATE
THERE REALLY REVIEWING THAT IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE ENTIRETY OF
THE STATE BUDGET WHICH I HAVE
RIGHT NOW ON BASED ON HOW THE
BUDGET THAT WAS SIGNED YESTERDAY
BY THE GOVERNOR'S AROUND TWO
HUNDRED AND ONE POINT FOUR
BILLION.
DOLLARS.
I WOULD OFFER TO TO THE
COMMITTEE ANOTHER WAY TO VIEW IT
THOUGH IS THROUGH THE PRISM OF
PROGRAMS.
AND I IF YOU LOOK AT NATURAL
RESOURCES AND THE ENVIRONMENT ON
THE PROVISIONS OF THE INITIATIVE
ON THOSE PARTICULAR SPECIAL
FUNDS WOULD BE DEVASTATING
BECAUSE MANY OF OUR PROGRAMS
UTILIZE THOSE FUNDS --
FOR THEIR IMPLEMENTATION AND FOR
MANY DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
US WITHOUT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS I WOULD NOTE I'M
AS THE CHAIR NOTED US THE OTHER
MEASURE S. B..
EIGHT SEVENTY TWO A CONTAINS A
CLARIFYING PROVISION ON THE
DEFINITION OF CANNABIS ON THAT
WAS AN ISSUE THAT I UNDERSTAND
THROUGH COMMITTEE STAFF WAS
RAISED BY SEVERAL --
LOCALITIES LEDGES AND ENSURES
THAT THE DEFINITION IS ITS
BROADER BASED ON DIFFERENT CODE
SECTIONS THAT DEFINE CANNABIS.
THANK YOU MISS COST AND WE
ANTICIPATE GETTING --
AB EIGHT EIGHTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
FROM THE SENATE AND VOTING IT ON
THE FLOOR TODAY.
BUT WE WILL NOT BE TAKING UP S.
B. EIGHT SEVEN TWO INTEL MONDAY.
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE MISTER STONE
[inaudible]
BOB.
THANK YOU I AM I READING THROUGH
THIS AND I KNOW THIS WAS THE
DEAL THAT WAS STRUCK AND I
MEASURE IN QUESTION WOULD BE
DEVASTATING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
BUT I WONDER WHAT WE'RE DOING TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HERE.
AS WELL ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO ARE
TRYING TO CREATE SALES OR TAXES
ON SUGAR SWEETENED BEVERAGES AND
AND OTHERS ESPECIALLY GIVING
THAT.
THE SAUDIS THAT'S THAT'S SORT OF
OUR POLITICAL DILEMMA.
I HAVE A STRUCTURAL PROBLEM
THOUGH WITH THIS BILL AS A THAT
BADLY BURNED UNIFORM SALES LOCAL
SALES AND USE TAX WAS SET UP.
SO THAT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
DON'T HAVE TO CLICK TAXES THE
STATE THEN DOES THAT AND
DISPERSES TO THEM.
AND SO IF A LOCAL JURISDICTION
ATTEMPTS TO DO SOMETHING
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO A SODA
TAX WHICH IS REALLY WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WE WE DON'T ALLOW
SALES TAX ON GROCERIES OR OTHER
ITEMS ANYWAY.
SO IT.
SEEMS THAT WE WOULDN'T WANT I
WOULDN'T EXPECT A LOCAL
JURISDICTION TO TRY AND TAX.
OTHER GROCERIES BUT THEY ARE
TRYING TO GO AFTER SODAS.
BUT IF THEY DO OR IF THEY DO
SOMETHING THAT OFFENDS THIS
STATUTE.
THEN WE ARE BY THIS BY THIS BILL
THEN ORDERING.
THE CALIFORNIA HARMONY TAX AND
FEE ADMINISTRATION TO CANCEL
THEIR CONTRACT FOR ALL OTHER
COLLECTION AND AND SPUR SPENT OF
TAXES.
SO THEY OFFENDERS IN ONE LITTLE
AREA.
AND WE HIT THEM WITH A VERY VERY
VERY LARGE HAMMER AND LEAVE ALL
THE LOCAL TAXES COLLECTION AND
DISBURSEMENT AT ALL THAT AND ALL
THE OTHER BENEFITS.
OF THE BRADLEY BURNS UNIFORM.
LOCAL SALES AND USE TAX LAW WE
JUST STRIP THAT AWAY FROM THEM --
WHO REALLY STRUGGLING WITH THE
DRACONIAN NATURE OF THAT AS A
PENALTY?
CAN YOU TELL WHY THIS IS THE WAY
IT S..
I CAN'T REALLY SPEAK TO THE
RATIONALE YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT THAT THERE IS A PROVISION
IN THE BILL THAT WOULD AND
BASICALLY DIRECT THAT DEPARTMENT
OF TAX ANTI ADMINISTRATION TO
CANCEL THEIR CONTRACT WITH
LOCALS FOR TAX COLLECTION.
ON AS A STATED PREVIOUSLY THIS
IS NOT AN ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSAL SO I CAN'T SPEAK TO THE
RATIONALE BEHIND THIS PARTICULAR
PROVISION.
AND I HAVE A QUESTION THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY THAT
ESPECIALLY SINCE WE HAVE NEVER
CHARTER CITIES AND OTHERS WHO
HAVE SPECIFIC CONSTITUTIONAL
AUTHORITY TO DO THINGS IN THE
STATE.
HAS WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO A
LOT WITH RESPECT TO TAXES BUT TO
CONFER A BENEFIT AND THEN TAKE
BACK.
A BENEFIT ESPECIALLY WHEN DUH.
PUNISHMENT SEEMS TO FAR OUTWEIGH
THE POTENTIAL CRIME HERE I'D
JUST.
I THINK THIS SETS A VERY BAD
PRECEDENT THAT.
I CAN'T REALLY ANSWER THAT
QUESTION THANK YOU [inaudible]
MR CARTER.
AND YEAH I THINK I GOT
CLARIFICATION OF UP HERE BUT
JUST WANT TO CONFIRM THAT THAT
JURISDICTION'S THAT.
NEED TO REAUTHORIZE.
I THINK THERE'S ONLY ONE OF THE
CITIES WOULD BE ABLE TO DO SO AS
FAR AS A NEW SORT OF TAX
[inaudible]
CORRECT.
NO YEAH THE IT ANY ARM.
IN THE TAX WAS IN PLACE PRIOR TO
JANUARY ONE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WOULD CONTINUE TO BE --
WHO EXIST AND COULD BE
REAUTHORIZED JUSTICE COULD BE
INCREASED OR COULD HAVE HAVE A
NEW TAX CORRECT BUT IT COULD I
THINK OF ONE OF THE CITIES?
RICHMOND BERKELEY.
AS A SUNSET AND THEY COULD
REAUTHORIZE CORRECT.
YES THE PROVISION STATES LOCAL
AGENCY MAY CONTINUE ELEVEN
O'CLOCK ENFORCER REVIEW
AUTHORIZE ANY TAX FEE OR OTHER
SETUP ON GROCERIES IMPOSED
EXTENDED OR INCREASED.
ON OR BEFORE JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO TO THE DEGREE
LOCALITY HOT IN THE EXISTING TAX
IN THIS AREA ON IF THERE WAS A
SENSE THAT THEY COULD EXTEND --
PUT A VOTER ABSOLUTELY DISAGREE
WITH THAT I THINK IS VERY VERY
CLEAR BY THE WAY THE LANGUAGE IS
TO JUST LET READ THAT THEY WOULD
HAVE.
TO THEY WOULD HAVE TO EXTEND IT
PRIOR TO THAT DATE.
THAT EXTENSION DONE AFTER THAT
DATE WOULD NOT BE ALLOWED INTO
THIS TO THIS THAT YOU
[inaudible]
YEAH.
THAT MISTER CHAIR.
COULD WE HAVE SOME CLARIFICATION
ON MISTER STONE'S QUESTION.
I RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE AS I
READ THAT SECTION AND BASICALLY
GRANDFATHERS AND THE LOCALITIES
THE HOTLINE IN EXISTENCE PRIOR
AND ALLOWS THEM TO REAUTHORIZE.
YOU THINK TO MY COLLEAGUES --
PLANES REAUTHORIZE WOULD NOT
INCLUDE INCREASING THAT --
BUT IF THEY HIDE SOMETHING IN
EXISTENCE THE HOW TO SUNSET THEY
WOULD BE ALLOWED TO REAUTHORIZE
SO LONG I'VE.
IT EXISTED PRIOR TO THE DATE
SPECIFIED.
AND THEN THE BIG PICTURE AS AYE
I THINK THIS IS A TERRIBLE
DECISION THAT WORK WERE MAKING.
VERY DISTURBED BY IT FIRST OF
ALL THE POLITICS HOW IT CAME
ABOUT BRIDGES.
THE POWER PLAY AND BEING FORCED
IN THE CORNER AND IN OUR CITY
HERE.
WE HAVE THE CITY COUNCIL THAT'S
DEBATING DOING A SUGAR SWEETENED
BEVERAGE POLICY TO ADDRESS THE
OBESITY EPIDEMIC BRING MORE P.
AND HEALTH PROGRAMS TO
UNDERSERVED AREAS.
AT THE SAME TIME WE HAVE A SALES
pUP NEXT YEAR TO ACTUALLY PUT ON
THE BALLOT NOW IS THAT FROM THE
COUNCIL.
TWENTY TWELVE THAT WOULD MEAN IF
IT DIDN'T PASS IT TO GET TWO
THIRDS VOTE THAT'S FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN CUTS.
TO PARKS RECREATION POLICE AND
FIRE SERVICE SO.
BUT THE CHOICES THAT WE HAVE
HERE ARE ARE BOTH THAT NOT GOOD
ONES AND WE HAVE TO EVALUATE
THAT BUT JUST.
I WANT TO EXPRESS MY MY GREAT
DISPLEASURE IN THIS WHOLE THAT
PROCESS IN THIS BILL BEFORE US.
I THINK IT WAS FROM.
I JUST REAL QUICK CAN YOU
OUTLINE HOW OLD THIS MORATORIUM
OR DEAL IS ENFORCED.
IF YOU CAN'T HAVE THIS
LEGISLATURE CAN'T BIND FUTURE
LEGISLATURE'S.
I'M SORRY COULD YOU REPEAT THE
QUESTION SIR CAN YOU X. EXPLAIN
TO ME HOW THIS DEAL AS ENFORCERS
MORATORIUM IS ENFORCED IF.
THIS LEGISLATURE CANNOT BIND
FUTURE LEGISLATURE'S.
IT'S THE STATUTE SO A LIKE ANY
OTHER STATUTE ON THE LEGISLATURE
RETAINS THE RIGHT TO AMEND
STATUE IN A FUTURE YEAR.
SO IS SO WHAT ALLEGES THAT SO
NEXT YEAR OR TWO YOU COULD
ANOTHER LEGEND YOU CAN CHANGE
THE STATUTE.
THAT'S CORRECT VICKI
[inaudible]
DON'T WORK.
ARE THERE OTHER --
INSTANCES WHERE.
WE'VE ACTUALLY PASSED BILLS THAT
TAKE AWAY.
CITIES RIGHT TO VOTE ON
SOMETHING.
THE REALLY BROAD QUESTION
IMMUNOASSAY CERTAINLY THERE ARE
THERE ARE.
AT WELL I WOULD SAY YOU KNOW
THERE HAVE BEEN OTHER ISSUES IN
WHICH THE STATE HAS A SIZE
TREATED UNIFORMLY THE ABILITY OF
A SEAT.
VOTE ON ITS ABILITY TO TAX.
A SOFT KIRSTEN LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I BELIEVE THERE
IS STATE STATUTE THAT LIMITS
LOCAL AUTHORITY TO IMPOSE.
TOBACCO [inaudible]
EXCISE TAXES.
AT SO.
TO TO OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS.
ON EITHER S. B. EIGHT SEVEN TWO
OR AB.
EIGHTEEN THIRTY OKAY SEEM NON
PUBLIC COMMISSURE CHAIR I'M I'M
JUST WONDERING IF THE LA O.
COULD CLARIFY --
MR STONE'S.
NAY IN THE DEBATE BETWEEN THEIR
IF THEY LIKE THE WAY AND
ABSOLUTE PLUS I'M SORRY AND YOU
FORTUNATE DON'T THINK WE CAN IT
REALLY DOES DEPEND ON THE
INTERPRETATION OF THE TERM RE
AUTHORIZE HERE IN THE LANGUAGE
AND AND WE'RE NOT.
I DON'T THINK WE'RE IN A
POSITION TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
KERR CLARIFICATION THIS TIME
UNFORTUNATELY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY SEEING NO OTHER COMMENTS
PUBLIC SUPPORT FOR THIS SPUR
THESE BILLS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TERRY
BRAND ON BEHALF OF SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
CALIFORNIA.
I THINK A ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY DID A VERY GOOD JOB OF
DESCRIBING --
THE ANGST AROUND THIS ISSUE --
I DON'T THINK ANYONE IS HAPPY
WITH.
HOW WE GOT HERE WHY WE GOT HERE
BUT WE'RE HERE?
AND THE CONSEQUENCES OF NOT
APPROVING THE S. OR SO GRAVE.
TWO LOCAL AGENCIES AND THE
PROGRAMS THAT THEY PROVIDE.
THE IT -- WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE COMPROMISE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
BRIAN NELSON ABOUT THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES ALSO SUPPORT
A COMPROMISE OFFER THE REASONS
STATED BY MY COLLEAGUE --
FORTUNATELY THIS IS --
THE SITUATION FIND THEMSELVES
AND BUT ARE WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS A PROVEN PATH TO MOVING
FORWARD TO AND PREVENTING A
WORST CASE SCENARIO THE
NEGATIVELY IMPACTS BY OUR
COMMUNITIES AND PROGRAMS THAT WE
CARE ABOUT THOSE COMMUNITIES
MOON.
FOR REALLY IS A QUESTION ABOUT
THE FUTURE OF OUR STATE --
SO WHAT RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
ABOUT.
STUCK SUPERZOOM HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA PROVIDE FIREFIGHTERS
HERE IN SUPPORT AS WELL WOULD
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES.
AND WE ARE REALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT IF THE INITIATIVE WERE TO
PASS IT WOULD TIE THE HANDS OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ABILITY TO
RAISE REENUES TO FUND PUBLIC
SAFETY SERVICES INCLUDING POLICE
AND FIRE.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS RIGHTS BUT
A COMPROMISE THINKING.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION FOR
THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED TO
ENSURE THAT LOCALES HAVE THE
TOOLS NECESSARY --
TO CONCEDE CRY THE SERVICES THAT
ARE CRITICAL TO THE COMMUNITIES
THEY SERVE OF YEARS APPLE
THINKING.
AMARO KNOW MAP THE CALIFORNIA
GROWERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
WHERE TOP ON BEHALF ORANGE
COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT --
DAVID JONES ON BEHALF OF MERE
DARRELL STEINBERG NOT THE CITY
OF SACRAMENTO AGREE WITH MR
MCCARTY SCOTT SEVERE AWKWARD
PLACE BUT OF THIS IS A VERY
DIFFICULT CHOICE IN THE MATTER
WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANKS.
DENNIS ALBION AB OUT THE GROCERY
MANUFACTURERS OF AMERICA THE
BRAND NAME COMPANIES THAT WE
REPRESENT.
A SUPPORT BILL.
I THINK YOU EITHER ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT.
OKAY.
MEMBERS OF PUBLIC IN OPPOSITION.
CHAIR MEMBERS KATHY MUST FOR
WITH THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION THINK WE JUST HAVE
TO ECHO MANY OF THE COMMENTS
THAT ARE MADE HERE BEEN HEREBY
THE MEMBERS.
WE ARE IN A TOUGH POSITION THIS
IS A PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE LOCAL
CITIES ARE GOING TO BE BARRED
FROM DEALING WITH LOCAL PUB
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES.
WE HAVE ON FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH
PERSPECTIVE ATTEMPTED TO DO THIS
ON THE STATEWIDE LEVEL SODA HAS
THWARTED THOSE EFFORTS THIS IS A
TOTAL POWER PLAY.
ON PUBLIC HEALTH IS THE LOSER
AND LOCALS HAVE ATTEMPTED TO
DEAL WITH THIS AND HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL IN THOSE AREAS THEY
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PULL TOGETHER
TAXES THAT ARE PUT THAT OF PUT
TOGETHER MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
GO TOWARD DEALING WITH PRE
DIABETES DIABETES.
HEART ALL AT THE OBESITY
EPIDEMIC WE'RE DEALING WITH
THESE COST AS WELL AND SO SAME
ARGUMENTS THAT THE FOLKS HAVE
MADE ON THE OTHER SIDE WILL MAKE
ON THIS SIDE THIS STOPS LOCALS
FROM DEALING WITH A LOCAL
PROBLEM --
WE HAVE CERTAINLY.
BEEN PRIOR COMMITTEE IN THE
PRIOR COMMITTEE ON THE SENATE
SIDE SAID WE WANT TO WORK WITH
US YEAH YOU SINCE WE ARE NOW
BEING STOPPED FROM DEALING WITH
THIS LOCALLY WHERE WE'VE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL WE WOULD LIKE TO WORK.
WITH FOLKS ON A STATEWIDE TAX
THEN IF THAT IS WHAT WE'RE WE'RE
HERE TO DO TODAY AND WOULD LIKE
TO SORT OF TALKED ALL WE
CERTAINLY WOULD LIKE TO TALK TO
ALL OF YOU MEMBERS ABOUT THAT.
BUT THESE ARE DOLLARS THAT ARE
KEY FOR LOCALS THE SOLVE A LOCAL
PROBLEM FOR PARTICULARLY LOW
INCOME INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
AND THESE ARE PRICES WE PAY AT
THE STATE LEVEL AS WELL SO FROM
THE HEART ASSOCIATION WE MUST
OPPOSE THIS BILL THINK.
CAN REALLY TELL THE CALIFORNIA
PAN ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK AND
ALSO IN OPPOSITION AT ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MISS MOSSBERG.
WE UNDERSTAND TRULY THE
PREDICAMENT THAT WE ARE IN TODAY
BUT GIVEN THE DISPROPORTIONATE
HEALTH AND PACKS THAT NEGATIVELY
IMPACT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
OBESITY DIABETES --
HEART DISEASE AND ALL OF THE
OTHER --
PUBLIC HEALTH AND TO OPPOSE THIS
A MEASURE.
SHARE GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN DIABETES ASSOCIATION WE
MUST REGRETFULLY OPPOSE THE BELL
WE UNDERSTAND THIS.
SITUATION THAT'S VERY
UNFORTUNATE THAT YOU ARE ALL AND
BUT WE MUST OPPOSE THE BELL. 46%
OF CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION
EITHER HAS PRE DIABETES OR
UNDIAGNOSED DIABETES WHEN YOU
COMBINE THAT NUMBER WITH
DIAGNOSED DIABETES WE ARE AT 55%
OF THE STATE'S POPULATION. FOR
THOSE REASONS WE MUST OPPOSE
THIS BILL BECAUSE THIS WOULD BE
AN EFFECTIVE TOOL FOR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO FIGHT THIS
EPIDEMIC IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MATTHEW MUST ON
BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH%
INSTITUTE WORLD SO IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AND I
ECHO THE COMMENTS ALREADY MADE.
I THINK BIG BIG BEVERAGE BIG
SODA KNOWS THAT THEY CAN'T WIN
ON THE MERITS IN THE ARGUMENT
AND THEY KNOW THAT THESE TAXES A
POPULAR.
AND WHERE THESE TAXES HAVE BEEN
PASSED FOR EXAMPLE IN THE CITY
OF BERKELEY.
THEY'RE HAVING AN IMPACT ON WAS
SEEING UNHEALTHY BEVERAGE SALES
GO DOWN AND HEALTHY BEVERAGE
SALES GO UP AS WELL AS THE OF
COURSE VERY IMPORTANT REVENUE.
SO I'M AGAIN WE'RE OPPOSED THANK
YOU.
CHAIRMAN BOURZAT OF MARTIN SMITH
WITH THE AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY
CANCER ACTION NETWORK AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN YOUR
COMMENTS WITH THE HARDEST
DECISION AND SEE PAN.
ON WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE THINKING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CHECK A MOSQUE ON BEHALF
OF PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES.
WE HAVE GRAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THIS BILL IN THIS PROCESS WE DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT REPLACING AN
AWFUL BILL WITH A BAD BILL AND
CLOSE PROCESS IS THE BEST WAY TO
DEAL WITH THIS.
HELLO MY NAME'S AS YOUR PRIZE.
AND WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSE OF
THIS BILL WE CAME.
PUTTING PROFIT OVER PEOPLE I AM
WITH LA CHEESY BUT THEY ARE
COLLISION FOR HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
ONCE AGAIN WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
HELLO MY NAME'S JACKIE ó HATA
AND I'M FROM STOCKTON AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
SODAS ARE NOT GROCERIES.
AND THEY MAKE A SET --
AT TWELVE I WAS DIAGNOSED OF PRE
DIABETES AND FOR ME THAT MEANT.
MEDICAL BILLS THAT MET MY FAMILY.
HAVING TO TAKE DAYS OFF WORK TO
TAKE ME TO APPOINTMENTS OUT OF
TOWN.
AND ADMIT MAJOR LIFE CHANGES
KNOWING THAT.
WHEN I STRUGGLED WITH THE SAME
JOURNEY THAT MANY KIDS ACROSS
THOUSANDS OF KIDS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA FACING?
MADE ME WANT TO GO OUT AND VOTE
AND DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
BUT NOW AT EIGHTEEN THE A BILLY
ABA HAS SHAMEFULLY RIPPED THAT
RIGHT AWAY FROM ME.
AND HAS LEFT COUNTLESS A
COMMUNITIES NOW UNABLE TO DEFEND
THEIR HEALTH.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS I MUST
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME IS
JASMINE SHERGILL AND I'M A
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT.
I'M MORE PROUD DAUGHTER OF
IMMIGRANTS MY PARENTS CAME HERE
HOPEFUL IN SEARCH FOR NEW
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEIR CHILDREN
WOULD HAVE TO FEEL EMPATHY WOULD
HAVE TO FACE THE SAME HARDSHIPS
ASK THEM.
HOWEVER I WAS BORN AND RAISED IN
A CITY WHERE THIEF NECESSARY
OPPORTUNITIES AND RESOURCES
CLOCK.
JOINING THE POLL WELL LESS ON A
BETTER HELP CAMPAIGN MY PRIMARY
GOAL WAS TO BE ACTIVE IN MY
COMMUNITY FOR THE INCREASE OF
YOUTH AND HEALTH PROGRAMS.
AS MANY OF YOU MAY KNOW STOCKTON
IF THE CITY WITH HIGH CRIME
HIGHER UNEMPLOYMENT RATES HYPE
DRUG USAGE WACKER FUNDING THE
LIST GOES ON BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY STOCK THEN IT'S A
CITY WITH A HIGH DIABETIC RAY.
36% OF OUR YOUTH ARE AFFECTED BY
PRE DIABETES OR DIABETES AND 78%
OF THEM DRINK SUGARY SWEET AND
BEVERAGE JEFF.
MY CAMPAIGN FOUND A SOLUTION TO
THIS PROBLEM TO HAVE A
DISTRIBUTOR SFI WE WORK FOR OVER
TWO YEARS TRYING TO IMPLEMENT
THE FEE.
ALL OUR HARD WORK AFFECTING
THIRD BASE AND SIGNATURES MIND
YOU AND THE HOT FUN WHEN IT WAS
LIKE A HUNDRED AND TWO HUNDRED
FIVE TO GRIEF.
IF OF NO USE NOW.
WHY BECAUSE OF THE AMERICAN
BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION?
THE AMERICAN BEVERAGE
ASSOCIATION SET BACK OVER THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS TRYING TO STOP
OUR WORK WELL FOR SO THEY DON'T
LOSE BUSINESS.
EVEN THOUGH THERE WORTH BILLIONS
AND BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
WHY CURRENTLY SPEND THAT MONEY
ON FUNDING HELPING YOUTH
PROGRAMS AND LOW INCOME CITIES
AFTER ALL THAT'S ALL MY CAMPAIGN
IS TRYING TO DO?
WHY ARE THEY HAVING THROUGH KIM
MEETING FOR THE GOVERNOR?
MOST IMPORTANTLY WIFE THE
GOVERNOR AND THE AMERICAN
BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION TAKING OUR
RIGHT TO VOTE AWAY.
IF IT'S OUTRAGEOUSLY SHAMEFUL
THE HEALTH OF ARE COMMUNITY
FIFTH MORE IMPORTANT THAN
CORPORATE FUNDS [inaudible]
YOU.
AMERICAN PARENT ASSOCIATION IF
TAKING OUR RIGHT TO VOTE AWAY
JUST SO THEY CAN CONTINUE TO
FILL THEIR POCKETS.
NEWS FLASH OUR COMMUNITIES HELP
IF NOT A FOR SALE FLY FANCHER
TODAY TELLING EVERYONE TO NOT
LET HISTORY REPEAT ITSELF TO
RISE UP AND DEFEND OUR RIGHTS
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN TAKEN AWAY
FROM US IN THE FIRST PLACE.
BANKIA.
HEY EVERYONE MY NAME IS ASHLEY
BUSCA IS HOME I AM ALSO OPPOSE
THIS BILL --
I'M FROM STARTING CALIFORNIA
WITH THE LESS SORT OF BETTER
HEALTH PROJECT.
I COME TO YOUR TODAY HEARTBROKEN
AND WHEN I HEARD ABOUT THE THIS
BILL I WAS IN COMPLETE DISBELIEF --
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON THE LIST OF
BETTER HEALTH FOR A YEAR.
AND I'M OUR GOAL WAS TO EDUCATE
OUR COMMITTEE ABOUT DIABETES IN
ORDER TO HELP MAKE STOCKTON
HEALTHIER.
AND DURING THIS PROJECT I MET SO
MANY INCREDIBLE PEOPLE WITH
INCREDIBLE STORIES --
I'VE HEARD ABOUT PEOPLE LOSING
LOVED ONES DISEASE OR OF KIDS
WHO ARE FORCED AT YOUNG AGES TO
TAKE CARE OF THE PARENTS BECAUSE
OF AMPUTATIONS OR OTHER
COMPLICATIONS.
I'VE SEEN KIDS LIKE MY SISTER
WHO AT FOUR YEARS OLD.
HOME SHE HAD THE AUTHORITIES PUT
OUT BECAUSE MY PARENTS DIDN'T
KNOWLEDGE INKING JUICE WAS
HARMFUL.
AND I MEAN CAN YOU REALLY BLAME
THEM.
IT'S OUR DUTY AS A SOCIETY TO
HELP EACH OTHER OUT IN NINE
CLUES EDUCATION AND PROJECTS
LIKE THESE.
I'M YOU MOVE WITH THE STORIES
I'VE LEARNED THAT THERE SO MUCH
HOPE IN THE COMMUNITY PEOPLE
WANTED CHANGE THEY WANT TO BE
BETTER SOMETIMES THEY JUST DON'T
KNOW HOW.
I'M WE WERE GIVING PEOPLE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THEY NEEDED WE
WERE GIVING THEM SOLUTIONS TO BE
HEALTHIER.
AND THE AMERICAN BEVERAGE
ASSOCIATION --
IS TAKING AWAY OUR RIGHT TO
OFFER THE SOLUTIONS AND IT'S
TAKING AWAY THE CREATIVITY FROM
YOUNG PEOPLE LIKE ME AND WHO
WANT TO MAKE A CHANGE IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
WE'RE TAKING AWAY NOT ONLY OUR
VOICES BUT ALSO OUR RIGHT TO
VOTE BECAUSE WE DON'T GET AN
OPTION OF CHOOSING IF WE WANT
THIS AND YOU KNOW WE DON'T WANT
THIS.
AND SO I ASK YOU ALL TO PLEASE
DON'T STAND DON'T SIGN THIS AND
STAND WITH US THE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS --
PEOPLE'S HEALTH IS WAY MORE
IMPORTANT THE CORPORATE WELF
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ANGELA
SO GOOD AND I'M A SEVENTEEN YEAR
OLD AND I WAS BORN AND RAISED IN
THE CITY ESTA.
DIABETES HAS ALWAYS BEEN A PART
OF MY LIFE AND HUNTING WAY I
REMEMBER BEING SIX YEARS OLD
SEEMING DRUM UP POKER STOMACH
WITH A STICK COLLECTING AND SING
HER DROPLETS FROM A FINGER.
I WOULD ALWAYS WONDER WHY SHE
DID IT OR WHAT SHE WAS DOING I
LATER DISCOVERED THAT THESE ARE
THE EFFECTS OF DIABETES.
THE STICK LIKE THINKS USE WAS
CALLED AN INSULIN PEN USED TO
CONTROL AND IMPROVE REQUESTED
WITH LEVELS.
AND THE REASON SHE DREW BLOOD
WAS TO MEASURE HER SUGAR LEVELS.
MY GRANDMOTHER WAS NEVER
EDUCATED ON WHAT CONSUMING THE
SUGAR SWEETENED BEVERAGES COULD
YOU HELP THE AMERICAN BEVERAGE
ASSOCIATION NEVER PROVIDED THIS
EDUCATION BECAUSE THEY WANTED
THEIR PROFIT.
OUR COMMUNITIES AND FAMILIES
HEALTH IS WAY MORE IMPORTANT
THAN CORPORATE PROFITS WE'RE
TRYING TO DO NOW IS TO PROVIDE
THIS EDUCATION TO OUR
COMMUNITIES TO TO PRESS. TO
PREVENT DIABETES.
AND THE ABA FUND PROGRAMS ARE
THE FUTURE GENERATIONS.
THE ABA TOOK THAT IDEA AND
CRUSHED THE POTENTIAL SUCCESS
WILL FUTURE FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION TODAY I'M HERE TO ASK
OUR ASSEMBLY MEMBERS TO TAKE A
STAND AGAINST THE EPA.
AND VOTE NO ONE SP EIGHT SEVENTY
TWO ND BE COMPETING TO GET
THINKING.
WELL I LIKE SAYING HELLO
EVERYONE.
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE
TALKING TO ALL OF YOU.
AM SO MY NAME'S DAVE ONLY ABOUT
I AM FROM STOCKTON I'M RECENTLY
TURNED.
SIXTEEN AND I'VE LIVED THERE MY
ENTIRE LIFE.
SO WHILE GIVING A SPEECH I JUST
BE HONORED IF WE CALL RAISE YOUR
HANDS IF YOU KNOW SOMEONE HAS
DIABETES JUST EVERYONE IN THE
AUDIENCE AND IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO STAND WITH ME IN THE
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
SO IF YOU'RE NOT RECENT HOW
RIGHT NOW I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT
YOU'RE VERY LUCKY BECAUSE IN
THIS ARTISTIC THAT WE'VE ALL
HEARD ALREADY DIED IS A HUGE
ISSUE.
SO YOU CAN'T ARGUE THAT DIABETES
AND OBESITY ARE A PROBLEM THE
UNITED STATES ONE OUT WORK
TOWARDS ID'S PREVENTION A FALL
IN THE FOOTSTEPS OF CITIES LIKE
BERKELEY OAKLAND SAXES GOING
ALBANY.
STOCKTON IS KNOWN AS GHETTO AND
IS KNOWN FOR HOMELESS EVER SINCE
TALKING BANKRUPTCY WHERE HAVE
OUR PROGRAMS GONE I SPENT
SUMMERS DOING NOTHING SITTING AT
HOME.
I MIGHT AS WELL BE DRINKING
BOTTLES THE CHEAPEST BOX.
SOURCE THE FROM THAT FIRST.
THIS IS WHY I'VE BEEN OF A PART
OF A MOVEMENT AND STOCKTON. TO
IMPROVE MY COMMUNICATIVE BETTER
PLACE TO LIVE.
THOUGH LESS SO TO BETTER HEALTH
PROJECT AS WERE ALL WEARING THE
SHIRTS INSTEAD OF GROWING UP
THINKING WE'RE SO UNFORTUNATE TO
HAVE BEEN BORN STOCKTON THERE'S
A HOPE BECOMES OUR COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING THIS COMES WITH
FINDING FUNDING BECAUSE WE
ALREADY KNOW MANY LEADS TO
CHANGE.
AS WE'VE SEEN HOW RAPIDLY THE
AMERICAN BAR ASSOCIATION'S COME
UP WITH LEGISLATION FROM BEHIND
THE SCENES TO PUT AN END TO ANY
FEE THAT WOULD HURT THEIR
PROFITS.
THE AMERICAN BEVERAGE
ASSOCIATION COULD USE MONEY FOR
POSITIVE CHANGE TO HELP
COMMUNITIES ARE BECOMING
INCREASINGLY DEVASTATED BY
DIABETES WHICH LATER THOUSANDS
REPUTATIONS RIDICULOUS COST
CLOSE TO DISEASE AND NOT SHOCKED
INSPIRED COMMITTEE ORGANIZATION
TO PREVENT THE DISEASE.
IN STOCK AND WE WANT HEALTH
EDUCATION WE WANT NUTRITION
EDUCATION WE WANT DIABETES
PREVENTION AND WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE THE PEOPLE HAVE THEIR
VOICES TAKEN AWAY TO ASK FOR
THESE PROGRAMS.
HE'S ARE JUST AS I WAS TO COME
UP WITH OUR OWN BECAUSE WE'VE
BEEN SERVING PEOPLE AND THESE
ARE THE KIND OF THINGS THAT THEY
WANT IN OUR COMMUNITY.
PLEASE DON'T AGREE WITH THIS
BILL BECAUSE UNLESS YOU'RE JUST
GOING LISSAN SOMETHING.
I WAS SOME PEOPLE DIE FROM
DIABETES THE SOMETHING THAT
YOU'RE VERY FOND OF NOW I
UNDERSTAND THE TOUGH SITUATION
THAT WERE AND WE'RE FACED WITH
EITHER THIS OR THE WHOLE TWO
THIRDS VOTING THING.
THE THING IS THAT'S GOING ON THE
BALLOT WE'RE GONNA HAVE THE
PEOPLE VOTE WHY DON'T WE LET THE
PEOPLE VOTE ON IT.
IF WE'RE SO CONCERNED ABOUT IT
BEING AGREED WITH THEN WE SHOULD
PROBABLY ORGANIZE AGAINST THAT
WE HAVE THAT POWERS COMMITTEE
ORGANIZERS AND WE CAN PUT A STOP
TO THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO AGREE
WITH THIS BILL JUST GET RID OF
THE TWO THIRDS THRESHOLD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR MY TIME.
HAVING HIS JANET PHILLIPS I'M
ALSO FROM STOCKTON COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER THERE AND I AM OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
PUTTING UP.
PUTTING IN WORK AROUND GETTING A
SODA TAX ON THE BALLOT THIS YEAR
IN STOCKTON FOR ABOUT TWO YEARS
NOW AND THE FACT THAT THE ABA
CAN DOES HAVE A SECRET MEETING
WITH THE GOVERNOR AND TAKE AWAY
OUR RIGHT TO DECIDE.
WHETHER OR NOT WE WANT THIS
INNER CITY IS RIDICULOUS.
ALSO DIABETES IS IS A HUGE
PROBLEM IN STOCKTON AND
CALIFORNIA AS A WHOLE OVER 50%
OF ADULTS IN THE STATE.
RD HAVE PRE DIABETES OR DIABETES.
MULTIPLE PEOPLE IN MY FAMILY
HAVE DIABETES OR HAVE PASSED
AWAY DUE TO COMPLICATIONS OF IT.
AND THIS WAS THE SORT OF TAX WAS
OUR WAY.
ON OUR PATHWAY TO HELP YOUR
COMMUNITY.
BECAUSE OF THIS BILL IT ARE
RIGHT. TO DECIDE THAT FOR
OURSELVES IS BEING TAKEN AWAY.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NEWS A NEW SHE
PARMAR I'M ALSO AND AND I'M ALSO
FROM STOCKTON I'M INCOMING
SENIOR.
SO I'M AGAINST THIS BILL BECAUSE
MYSELF AND OTHER YOU CAN
STOCKTON HAVE PUT IN AND LIST
EFFORTS TO EDUCATE OUR COMMUNITY
AND RAISE AWARENESS ON THE
DIABETES LIKE EPIDEMIC.
AND THIS BILL HAS STOPPED US
FROM THE VOTING AND HAS SURPLUS
OF OUR VOTING RIGHTS I STAND
HERE TODAY ASKING THE ELECTED
OFFICIALS WHO HAVE THE PRIVILEGE
TO VOTE ON S. B. EIGHT SEVEN TWO
AND A. B. EIGHTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
TO VOTE AGAINST THIS BILL AND
RESTORE FAITH IN.
OUR COMMUNITIES.
HELLO MY NAME IS NICHOLSON
SEMANA LIKE IN MANY OF THE
PEOPLE YOU HEARD SPEAK TODAY I
AM A STOCKTON RESIDENT I AM
EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD AND I AM
OPPOSED TO BOTH OF THESE BILLS.
I M. OPPOSE THEM FOR THE REASON
THAT MY COLLEAGUES ABOUT LINE
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT
DIABETES IS SUCH AN EPIDEMIC AND
THE SODA TAX THAT WE WANT TO
IMPLEMENT OUR CITY WOULD.
GO TOWARDS FINDING THE AN ATTACK
ON THIS HEALTH EPIDEMIC.
BECAUSE OF TWO THINGS LIKE YOUTH
PROGRAMS OR DO THINGS LIKE
HEALTH EDUCATION OR COMMUNITY
GARDENS LIKE BERKELEY DID OR
WATER FOUNTAINS SUCH AS OAKLAND
OR ANYTHING ELSE.
BUT IN ADDITION TO THAT I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO CALL TO ATTENTION
THE PRECEDENT THAT PASSING A
BILL SUCH AS THIS WOULD PLACE
FOR COMPANIES LIKE THE AMERICAN
BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION AND BIG
TOBACCO.
AND ANY OTHER LARGE CORPORATIONS
THAT HAVE A LOT OF MONEY AND
DISAGREE WITH SOMETHING THAT IS
HAPPENING.
PASSING A BILL SUCH AS THIS
WOULD SET THE PRESIDENT THAT IF
YOU HAVE ENOUGH MONEY AND YOU
HAVE ENOUGH --
INFLUENCE WITHIN THE GOVERNMENT
YOU CAN PASS WHATEVER BILL YOU
LIKE JUST SO THAT YOU WOULD HAVE
TO PAY ADDITIONAL TAXES IN THE
FUTURE.
SO -- AS YOU
OF VOTE ORDERED AS YOU DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT TO VOTE ON THIS I
WOULD LIKE TO RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU TO OPPOSE THIS BUT I THINK
IT.
HELLO MY NAME IN THE US YOU
MILLIONS.
I AM OPPOSED CITIES BILLS MIKE
MARQUARD LEASE.
SO IT IS NOT A GROCERY IN FACT
SODA HIS POISONING.
CAUSING LIFE THREATENING TO
DISEASES LIKE DIABETES.
WHY IS TO ABA ALLOWED? TO DO
SHADY BACKGROUND DEALS.
BUT WE ARE NOT ALLOWED TO VOTE
THANK YOU [inaudible]
HELLO.
HELLO MY NAME IS JEFF NORA HOA
AND UPCOMING JUNIOR AND THIS
ABSOLUTE RIDICULOUS.
A 50% LABELS OVER MY HEAD EVERY
TIME I SEE A DOCTOR.
I HAVE A 50% CHANCE OF BEING
DIABETES OR PREDIABETES.
YOU KNOW WHAT I WANT TO CHANGE
SOMETHING MY COMMUNITY.
AND ALL THE HARD WORK ONE HALF
YEARS.
DOWN THE DRAIN IF YOU PASS THIS
BILL.
WE ARE TRYING TO GET BETTER
HEALTH AND YOUR COMMUNITY.
AND ABA WAS A STORY THAT AND
JUST WANT TO PUT MONEY INTO OUR
POCKETS.
THIS IS WHY I'M OPPOSING THIS
BILL PRISON THANK YOU --
HIGH ARMENIANS I THINK HYPHEN IN
OF ALL SOME STOCKTON AND I'M
AGAINST THIS BILL MOSTLY BECAUSE
I'M WITHOUT SOMETHING SUCH AS
THE FEDERAL TAX BEING
IMPLEMENTED.
STOCKTON WON'T GET THAT POSITIVE
CHANGE SUCH AS BERKELEY BECAUSE
IT BUCKLEY THE SAW THOSE --
OPTIONS OF UNHEALTHY JINX BEING
THE CONSUMPTION RATES BEEN
LOWERED AND OPTIONS SUCH AS
WATER THAT CONSUMPTION RATE
INCREASING SO I FEEL LIKE WITH
THAT SO TO TAX BEING IMPLEMENTED --
PEOPLE LIKE WITH DIABETES RATE
FELL PROBABLY BUMP UP FROM THAT
36% BECAUSE WITHOUT PROPER --
EDUCATION WITH THEIR OR ALL THE
POSITIVE CHANGES PEOPLE WON'T
REALLY NO.
THANK YOU.
HI EVERYONE MY NAME IS YOU DRUG
CON AND I REPRESENTED THE STOCK
DON'T YOU.
AND I'M.
I GIVE MY ONE THE HOW OF YOURS
IN TO THIS CAMPAIGN WHILE I WAS
TAKING NINETEEN UNITS AND THE
COLLEGE AND A LOT OF ALL THE
RESPONSIBILITIES.
THAT'S NOT FAIR THIS FAIR AND
THAT BETTEGA OVER --
RICE TOWARD.
WE NEED TO AWARD RE READ TO YOU
ON THE NEED TO WAR.
AND I'M AGAINST THE REAL THING
BICU.
HELLO MY NAME IS GARY SAWS ARE
I'M A SENIOR IN HIGH SCHOOL FROM
STOCKTON.
AND I'M HERE BECAUSE I ALONG
WITH MANY OTHERS HAVE BEEN
WORKING HARD TO BRING HOPE TO MY
COMMUNITY.
NOT I WANT TO STOP WE DESERVE
THE CHANCE TO VOTE ON THIS WHICH
WILL AFFECT VOTES THINK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MELISSA
TELEPHONE SAYS AND SEVENTEEN
YEARS OLD I'M A STUDENT FROM
MADISON HIGH SCHOOL.
I'M HERE TO EMPHASIZE AT SODAS
ARE NOT GROCERIES GROCERIES ARE
FOODS THAT YOU NEED YOU DO NOT
NEED SODA AND THIS IS WHY I AM
OPPOSING THIS BILL THINK YOU --
HI MY NAME'S MACKENZIE MORENO --
I AM GOING TO BE A SOPHOMORE IN
HIGH SCHOOL.
BONE AYE POSES BILL BECAUSE
COMMUNITIES AND THE STOPPING
COMMUNITY HAVE DIABETES OR
PREDIABETES --
AND I FEEL LIKE WHEN I STARTED
THIS PROJECT EFFORT LIKE.
MAYBE THIS COULD BE SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN HELP PEOPLE LIKE YOU
KNOW SAVE A LIFE BECAUSE SO MANY
PEOPLE DIE OR END UP IN HOSPITAL.
BECAUSE OF THIS REASON AND FOR
THE SEASON I OPPOSE AGAINST
THOSE.
HI MY NAME IS EVER CENTERS AND I
JUST LIKE MY FELLOWS I OPPOSED
HIS BILL AND I HOPE YOU GUYS ON
PASSED [inaudible]
NINETY HI EVERYONE --
MY COLLEAGUES ALREADY SPOKE
ABOUT THE DIABETES EPIDEMIC THIS
HELPS ALLEVIATE AND NOW LIKE TO
SPEAK ABOUT THE EDUCATIONAL
RAMIFICATIONS IS GOING TO HAVE.
OF THAT NOT ONLY DOES THE STATE
TASK A STATE BY THE CITY TAX.
FUND EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS IT
HELPS KITNA KIDS STAY OFF THE
STREETS AND IT PROMOTES
EDUCATION AND HELPS IT HELPS
BREAK DISCONTINUOUS A CONTINUOUS
CYCLE OF POVERTY SOMETHING THAT.
THE RESIDENTS OF SOFT AND VERY
FAMILIAR WITH AND IT HELPS KIDS
GO TO COLLEGE INSTEAD OF JUST.
WORKING MINIMUM WAGE JOBS AND
DROPPED OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL AND
SO FOR THAT REASON I OPPOSE THIS
BILL THANK.
HI MY NAME IS TAHAR REYNOLDS
WITH THE ORGANIZING IN
LEADERSHIP ACADEMY AND I'VE HAD
THE HONOR OF BEING AN ORGANIZER
TRAINER WITH THESE AMAZING YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO ARE SPARKING A
MOVEMENT IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
AND THEY COULD BE DOING ANYTHING
ELSE WITH THEIR SUMMER AND
THEY'RE HERE SPEAKING TO YOU
BECAUSE THIS IS A ISSUE THAT
DIRECTLY AFFECTS THEM.
SO I URGE YOU TO PLEASE VOTE NO
ON S. B..
EIGHT AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MORNING EVERYONE I'M OUT ACROSS
THE AND ALSO I'M HERE BECAUSE I
WAS PART OF THE MOVEMENT IN
OAKLAND --
TO PASS THOSE SODA TAX.
BACK IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND WE'RE
GOING OUT INTO THE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING OUR COMMUNITY WE GOT
TO HEAR FROM COMMUNITY MEMBERS
HOW THEY WERE AFFECTED BY
DIABETES THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
HAS AFFECTED MY FAMILY FOR MANY
GENERATIONS.
EFFECT IN MANY OF THE FAMILIES
IN THE COMMUNITY IN OAKLAND AND
WE KNEW THAT THIS WAS A CHANCE
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO BRING
RESOURCES. TO PREVENT THAT CYCLE
FROM CONTINUING HOPEFUL THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE PROVIDING THAT FOR
OTHER CITIES AROUND THE STATE.
THAT WE HOPE THAT YOU CAN GOING
THAT YOU'LL HEAR COURT FIGHTING
DIABETES IN THE MANY COMMUNITIES
AND IN OUR STATE --
BY VOTING DOWN THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
GOING EVERYONE MY NAME IS
CHRISTIAN OR SEE I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE ORGANIZING
LEADERSHIP ACADEMY.
I'VE HAD THE UNIQUE PLEASURE OF
WORKING ON EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THE SURE STREAM BEVERAGE TAXES
IN CALIFORNIA --
AND WORKING WITH YOUTH AND NOT
JUST THE SEE IT HERE TODAY WHO
ARE AMAZING FOR YOUTH FROM EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THESE COMMUNITIES
WHO HAVE.
COME TO THIS CALL TO ACTION AND
TAKE ON THE AMERICAN BEVERAGE
ASSOCIATION.
I WAS REALLY BECOME THE NEXT
TOBACCO I'M IS AFFECTING OUR
FAMILIES I YOU KNOW IT IT WAS
VERY DIFFICULT TO WAKE UP ON
SUNDAY MORNING AND READ THE NEWS --
WHEN THEY WERE WORKING SO HARD
TO GO BEFORE CITY COUNCIL I CAN
DO THIS MONTH TO GET SOMETHING
ON THE BALLOT?
NOW THEY GOT NOTHING TO DO NOW
WE GOTTA FIGURE OUT A NEW
STRATEGY.
THE BIG CONCERN THAT I HAVE HERE
IS HIGHER TAKING VOTERS RIGHTS
AWAY FROM THAT.
PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT TO
VOTE ON THIS PROPOSITION THAT IS
BEING PUT ON THE BALLOT BY ABA.
SPECIAL INTEREST UNION SHOULDN'T
DECIDE WHAT THE VOTERS WANT.
VOTERS ARE SMART THEY CAN MAKE A
GOOD CHOICE [inaudible]
WEAPON DECIDE RIGHT BUT WE HAVE
TO PUT UP A FIGHT.
AND WE CANNOT SPECIAL INTERESTS
WENT SPECIALLY IN THESE TIMES
WHERE CALIFORNIA'S THAT SHINING
CITY ON THE HILL.
THAT'S PROVIDING HOPE TO THE
NATION.
WHERE WE PROVIDING THEM NOW?
BY MAKING A DEAL WITH SPECIAL
INTEREST.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ZACH RECORD VOTE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION. FOR ALL OF THE
REASONS STATED WE ARE OPPOSED TO
BOTH BILLS.
GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MICHELLE GIVENS AND I'M
WITH THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND WE ARE
ACTUALLY WE TAKE WE TOOK A
CONCERNS POSITION ON THIS BILL
BECAUSE YOU RCOGNIZE THE
DIFFICULT POSITION THAT WE'VE
BEEN PLACED IN AS PART.
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AND I THINK.
IN SOME OF THE ELOQUENT
TESTIMONY AS YOU'VE HEARD BEFORE
YOU ARE READY WE RECOGNIZE THE
VALUE OF OF TAXES ON SODAS IN
SUGAR SWEETENED BEVERAGES
RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S NOT JUST A A
FUNDING SOURCE FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES.
BUT IT ALSO RAISES AWARENESS
ABOUT THE LINKAGE BETWEEN THE
SUGARY BEVERAGES AND CHRONIC
CONDITIONS SUCH AS DIABETES AND
OBESITY.
AND IT ALSO --
HELPS TO REDUCE CONSUMPTION IN
THAT MANNER AND SO IT'S REALLY
DIFFICULT FOR US TO SEE THE
LOCAL ABILITY TO RAISE AND TAXES
ON THESE BEVERAGES.
AYE HINDER THROUGH THIS BAD
THROUGH THIS MEASURE BUT WHAT WE
DO RECOGNIZES THAT SHOULD THE
INITIATIVE GO THROUGH IT WOULD
BE MUCH MORE DAMAGING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN TERMS OF
RESTRICTING OUR ABILITY TO RAISE
AT TAXES AND FEES ON A WHOLE
HOST OF AREAS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
INCLUDING MAKING IT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR GIVEN THE TWO
THIRDS SWELLED AND SO THAT FOR
THOSE REASONS AND WE JUST WANTED
TO STATE OUR CONCERNS WITH
APPROACH.
BUT ALSO WOULD LIKE TO I REALLY
EMPLOYER SOME CONVERSATION
AROUND A STATEWIDE SOLUTION FOR
FUNDING PREVENTION AND REDUCING
CONSUMPTION AND WOULD LIKE AND
WOULD STAND READY TO AND TO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
AND THE ADMINISTRATION ON A
STATEWIDE SORT ATTACKS OR SUGAR
SWEET WITH EFFORTS TO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY CONDUCT TO THE COMMITTEE
MISTER BLOOM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
ALL HAVE FLOOD MORE. TO SAY
ABOUT THIS TOPIC WHEN.
THE A MEASURE REACHES THE FLOOR
LATER THIS MORNING.
A BUT I I WANTED.
TO SAGE THAT I COME TO THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING COULD I A
AND AND THE LATER VOTE ON THIS
ON THE FLOOR.
OUT WITH JUST AT A SENSE OF
ABJECT DISCUSSED [inaudible]
ABSOLUTE [inaudible]
SCOTT STE.
AND I WANT TO ADDRESS.
MY COMMENTS TO YOU BY MY
COLLEAGUES --
BUT I WANT.
TO PARTICULARLY SPEAK TO THOSE
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE WHO
ARE WATCHING THIS UNFOLD.
AN I WANNA SPEAK ALSO TO THOSE
WHO SIGNED PETITIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE BECAUSE THERE WERE
OVER FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE WHO SIGNED PETITIONS.
AT THE BEHEST OF PEOPLE WHO CAME
TO THEM IN YOUR FARMERS MARKETS
IN YOUR SUPERMARKETS IN YOUR
STORES AROUND YOUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES.
AND THEY WERE TOLD.
THAT IF THEY SIGNED ON THE
DOTTED LINE IT WOULD HELP PUT A
MEASURE ON THE BALLOT.
THAT WOULD BE A TAXPAYER
GOVERNMENTS.
TO TOOK ONLY PASS.
LOCAL REVENUE MEASURES WITH THE
TWO THIRDS VOTE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WERE TOLD.
AND WHO PAID FOR THAT.
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT AND A
QUARTER MILLION DOLLARS.
HAS BEEN RAISED AS OF JUNE
TWENTY THIRD IN SUPPORT OF THAT
MEASURE.
ONLY ABOUT THREE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS OF THAT MONEY
WAS SPENT BUT IT WAS I'M QUITE
CERTAIN.
VIRTUALLY ALL SPENT ON SIGNATURE
GATHERING.
AND THE SOURCE OF THOSE FUNDS.
SEVEN MILLION OF THAT EIGHT IN A
QUARTER ROUGHLY SEVEN MILLION.
COCA COLA THREE MILLION DOLLARS
[inaudible]
PEPSI. TWO POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS.
DOCTOR PEPPER ALMOST A MILLION
DOLLARS AND THEN SMALLER AMOUNTS
BY RED BULL AND THE AMERICAN
BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION WHICH IS IN
TURN SUPPORTED BY ALL THE
BEVERAGE COMPANIES.
AND YOU HAVE.
TO ASK YOURSELF WILL YOU KNOW
WHY ARE THOSE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUPPORTING THIS TWO THIRDS VOTE
MEASURE.
AND I THINK YOU KNOW VERY FEW
PEOPLE PROBABLY GOT TO THAT
POINT AS THEY WERE THINKING
ABOUT SIGNING BECAUSE OF THESE
PETITIONS.
BUT NOW WE KNOW.
BECAUSE WE'RE ALL BEING
VICTIMIZED HERE BY A CLASSIC
BAIT AND SWITCH.
PEOPLE WHO SIGN THOSE PETITIONS
WERE EXPECTING ONE THING AND
WHAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY GONNA GET
[inaudible]
IS.
THE STATE ASSEMBLY VOTING TO
TAKE AWAY THEIR RIGHT TO VOTE AT
ALL ON A COUPLE OF ISSUES.
NOT BY TWO THIRDS VOTE.
THEIR DEMOCRATIC RIGHT TO VOTE
IS BEING TAKEN AWAY.
WE WON'T BE ABLE TO VOTE ON
LOCAL SODA TAXES WHICH HAVE
PROVEN POPULAR.
AMONGST LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO VOTE.
TECH THEIR OCEANS FROM PLASTIC
POLLUTION [inaudible]
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT
[inaudible]
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS
BECAUSE WE DO THIS.
WITH A GUN TO OUR HEAD.
AND WERE PLACED IN THAT POSITION
AND FRANKLY WE KINDA PUT
OURSELVES IN THIS POSITION BY
TRYING TO REFORM.
THE INITIATIVE SYSTEM BY
PROVIDING THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
NEGOTIATE AND WITHDRAW A MEASURE
AND WHAT WE FIND OUT.
WE FIND OUT THAT NOT ONLY IS THE
INITIATIVE.
SYSTEM BEING ABUSED IN BEING
VICTIMIZED BY A AYE A YOU KNOW
ANYBODY WHO CAN WRITE A BIG
ENOUGH CHECK TODAY TO CUT TO
COLLECT SIGNATURES.
CAN GET SOMETHING ON THE BALLOT
ANYBODY WITH A CRACKPOT IDEA CAN
DO THIS.
AND MEAN TO SAY THAT EVERY
BALLOT MEASURE.
THAT QUALIFIES AS A CRACKPOT
MEASURE BUT YOU KNOW SOME OF
THOSE IDEAS THAT ARE OUT THERE
YOU READ ABOUT THEM IN YOUR
NEWSPAPER SO WE TRIED TO DO
SOMETHING TO REFORM THAT.
AND NOW THE REFORM.
IS PICKING ABUSED AND WERE THE
VICTIMS OF OUR OWN REFORM
[inaudible]
SO I I AM DEEPLY DISAPPOINTED.
THAT WE FIND OURSELVES HERE
TODAY.
I I SAY TO THOSE WHO SIGNED THE
PETITIONS.
WE'RE GONNA TRY AND FIX THE
SYSTEM.
AND TO THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE OVER
HERE WHO WORK SO HARD ON THIS
ISSUE AND WHO UNDERSTAND THE
ISSUE AND A AND AND AND COME
HERE TO SPEAK TO US NOT
UNDERSTANDING.
HOW WE COULD DO SUCH A THING?
I A I SAY TO YOU DON'T GIVE UP
HOPE.
AND STAY ACTIVE.
AND MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE HERE
IN OUR FACES TELLING US.
WHAT YOU WANT US TO DO DON'T
GIVE UP HOPE?
LET ME JUST CLOSE BY TALKING ON
A A LITTLE BIT AND I WILL TALK
MORE ABOUT THIS LATER ABOUT TARA
ARE.
I EPIDEMIC OF OBESITY AND
DIABETES WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT
I'VE WORKED ON FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS NOW AND I DON'T THINK IT'S
A OF ON THE I THINK EVERYBODY
KNOWS THAT I'VE BEEN VERY ACTIVE
AND HAVE HAD.
TO OF MULTIPLE PIECES OF
LEGISLATION ON ON ON THIS TOPIC
AND I UNDERSTAND THEY'RE JUST
PEOPLE WHO DISAGREE BUT YOU
CANNOT DISAGREE WITH FACTS.
YOU NOT ENTITLED TO YOUR OWN
FACTS HERE FACTS ARE FACTS WE
ARE FACED WITH AN EPIDEMIC.
PEOPLE ARE GETTING SICK PEOPLE
ARE DYING.
AND THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
STUDIES AND THE EVIDENCE THAT
OUT THAT IS OUT THERE POINTS TO
SUGAR.
AND IN PARTICULAR SUGAR
SWEETENED BEVERAGES SO WE NEED
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
BECAUSE THE LIVES OF
CALIFORNIANS.
ARE DEPENDING UPON US TO DO THAT.
AND OF THOSE CALIFORNIANS IT'S
PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
DISADVANTAGED [inaudible]
PEOPLE WHO ARE MOST AFFECTED.
THE LET ME JUST CLOSE AGAIN BY
TELLING YOU HOW HOW.
A DEEPLY EMBARRASSED DIANNE BY
WHERE WE ARE TODAY AND THE I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO STAY ACTIVE.
THANK YOU FOR INDULGENCE MISTER
CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISS BLOOM AYE LET LET
ME JUST ALSO.
HOME [inaudible]
JUST FOR EVERYBODY IN THE
AUDIENCE JUST THANK MISTER BLOOM
FOR ALL HIS.
LEADERSHIP HE'S BEEN OUR LEADER
ON THIS ISSUE OF SODA TAXES --
IN OUR HOUSE WHO HAS REALLY BEEN --
QUITE ACTIVE --
QUIET HOME.
IT'LL JUST --
JUST TO A WARRIOR IN THIS REALM --
LET ME LET ME JUST THANK ALL THE
FOLKS ESPECIALLY THE YOUNG FOLKS
FROM STOCKTON WHO CAME HERE. TO
GIVE TESTIMONY IS ABSOLUTE
WONDERFUL TO SEE YOU ALL HERE --
IT IS UNFORTUNATE THAT YOU ARE
HERE UNDER THESE --
TYPES OF CIRCUMSTANCES.
WE YOU KNOW I WOULD LIKE TO
ALIGN MYSELF WITH MANY OF THE
COMMENTS TO MY COLLEAGUES.
MADE REGARDING THE PROCESS
REGARDING THE VERY CHALLENGING
SITUATION WITH BATES OURSELVES
WITH THAT AS WELL AS THE CHOICE
THAT WE HAVE.
BEEN FORCED TO MAKE TODAY --
HAVING SAID THAT WHAT I WOULD
SAY ESPECIALLY TALL THE YOUNG
FOLKS WHO --
HAVE BEEN WORKING SO HARD AND
STOCKTON THAT --
WHILE TODAY IS POTENTIALLY A
BUMP IN THE ROAD TO FIGHT ON
THIS ISSUE IS NOT OVER.
I COME FROM A CITY THAT DID PASS
A SWORD ATTACKS ARE SORT OF TAX
WILL CONTINUE TO STAND.
IN SAN FRANCISCO A AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN WE'VE ALREADY SEEN THE
BENEFITS AGAIN --
MISTER BLOOM ALLUDED TO THIS THE
BENEFITS OF A SODA TAX AND THE
DECREASES THE DECREASE IN THE
CONSUMPTION OF SODA.
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY --
WE'VE SEEN THIS ALSO --
DON'T JUST EXACT SAME ANALOGY
WHEN WE STARTED CHARGING PEOPLE
A NICKEL OR QUARTER TO PURCHASE
A GROCERY BAG WE SAW CONSUMPTION
GO DOWN IT'S VERY SIMPLE.
THIS ACTUALLY WORKS WHICH IS WHY
WE ARE HERE.
I HAVING SAID THAT WE ARE AS
MISS COST DIMENSION WE ARE
TAKING LEGISLATIVE ACTION MISTER
FONG AS A QUESTION.
DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE CAN'T TAKE
WHICH IMPACT LEGISLATIVE ACTION
LATER.
SO THIS FIGHT IS ABSOLUTELY NOT
OVER WE KNOW THAT THIS ISSUE
CONTINUES IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
THAT THIS IS VERY MUCH A
CHALLENGE THAT WE ALL HAVE TO
FACE AS STATE --
I'M PROUD TO COME FROM THE
COMMUTE THAT THAT FACED THIS
EARLY.
BUT M. VERY CONCERNED THAT OTHER
COMMUNITIES CANNOT FALL COURSE
[inaudible]
AS WELL [inaudible]
SO HA.
TALL OF YOU ESPECIALLY FROM
START AND WE INTO MISTER BLOOM
BACKORDER WE WELCOME YOU BACK WE
WILL NEED YOU BACK.
I KNOW THAT MISTER BLOOM HAS
BEEN IN THIS ROOM BEFORE --
UNSUCCESSFULLY TRYING TO GET HIS
BILL THROUGH --
HE'S GONNA NEED YOUR HELP NEXT
TIME HE BRINGS OUT BILL FORWARD
SO YOU CAN COME UP HERE.
AND TESTIFY FOR SOMETHING YOU
BELIEVE AND THAT YOU'RE IN FAVOR
OF I'M.
WE AGAIN --
IT OFF OFTENTIMES AVE TO MAKE
VERY DIFFICULT CHOICES TODAY IS
ONE OF THOSE DAYS --
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT TOMORROW
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP FIGHTING.
AND THE NEXT DAY AND NEXT YEAR
WILL BE BACK.
AND I'M VERY PROUD TO BE PART OF
THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY THIS
ASSEMBLY CAUCUS --
AND WE DO HAVE TO MAKE VERY
DIFFICULT CHOICES.
BUT THE SAME TIME WE'RE NOT
GOING TO STOP FIGHTING WE'RE NOT
GONNA STOP FIGHTING FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES AND WE'RE NOT GOING
TO STOP FIGHTING ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE [inaudible]
UP WITHOUT.
THIS COMMITTEE WILL BE A JERK
THANK YOU